[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
video
this past summer a brand new kono Suba
anime project was announced although we
are not sure if this project will be a
full season 3 an OVA or maybe a movie
whatever it is I think that now is the
perfect time for anime uproar to finally
make a video on kono Suba now I know
what you're thinking here on the channel
we make a lot of serious Theory videos
explained videos fact videos so I'm sure
that like other respectable youtubers
you are expecting us to make a
well-researched analytical video about
why
kono Suba works as a comedy series why
it is an effective satire of the
oversaturated essica genre and so on
well that's not going to be happening
because in this video we will leave all
of the useless trivia luyties such as
critical thinking behind in order to
tackle the biggest and most important
question of this series who is the true
best girl and the most qualified waifu
in kono Suba so get your body pillows
ready boys because we are about to leap
headfirst into the kono supa waifu wars
and speaking of body pillows I
personally never owned a body pillow in
my life but as I was getting ready to
make this video I was contacted by the
anime dakimakura pillow company and they
offered to send me one of their body
pillows to check it out so I thought
what better way to dramatically reveal
who I think is the true best girl in
kono Suba then by showing her to all of
you on my very first body pillow right
here in this video that reveal will come
later on so stay tuned and if you want
to check out the anime dakimakura our
pillow shop i will leave a link in the
description just keep in mind that some
of their stuff is not safe for work and
may not be suitable for all ages keep in
mind that they are not paying me money
to make this video and they didn't tell
me what to say or not to say in this
video they merely sent me one of their
pillows to check out if you end up
enjoying this type of video don't forget
to leave a like to let me know and if we
receive a lot of support let's say 1000
likes I will make videos about who is
the true best girl in other anime as
well and now let's get into it our first
best girl candidate is aqua the radiant
and beautiful goddess of water aqua is
hyperactive easygoing and generally
careless with little regard about the
consequences of all of the crazy things
that she does she doesn't really think
before she speaks or acts and she is
quite vain so it is easy to get a
reaction out of her by either
complimenting her or mocking her she has
impressive magical powers but when she
uses her magic things often go wrong so
even though her powers are very useful
they also tend to get her and everyone
around her in trouble while she has a
sincere personality and this is quite
endearing she can also be quite gullible
and stubborn her choice of outfits
though can't argue with that
next up we got Megaman an arch Wizard of
the Crimson magic clan mega mean is
obsessed with explosion magic and she
insists on creating a massive explosion
at least once a day which makes for an
interesting situation since her
explosions tend to cause a lot of
collateral damage her explosion magic is
impressive and she can be quite
effective in battle but the big drawback
is that she can only use it once before
essentially collapsing and then she
requires a long rest period before she
can use her magic again because she
refuses to learn other types of magic
Megaman is completely reliant on other
members of her party to protect her
after she uses explosion magic the
explosion magic aside she is quite
fun-loving in general and one of her
best qualities is her loyalty to Kazuma
and the rest of the party then we have
darkness real-name dustiness for the LA
latina
Lola Pina darkness is a beautiful blog
Crusader with exceptional courage and
masochistic tendencies
she takes pleasure in sacrificing her
body at the hands of the enemy and she
even gets enjoyment out of being mocked
verbally which often freaks out the
members of her own party as well as her
enemies
despite her masochism which can be
off-putting darkness takes great pride
in being a crusader and she shows
throughout the series that she has honor
and integrity she isn't afraid to stand
up for what's right she cares deeply
about her friends and she is willing to
put her life on the line for her allies
darkness is actually a member of a
wealthy noble family and the heiress to
her family fortune but she doesn't want
people to know this because she wants to
be respected on her own merits not
because of her family status as a sword
wielding Crusader one would expect her
to be skilled with the sword but
unfortunately she has terrible accuracy
and almost always misses her intended
target next up is Wiz an undead Lich Wiz
or we zoo owns a magic item shop in the
town of Excel she is a beautiful and
well-developed character and get it
anyway
despite being undead and having
previously been affiliated with the
devil King Wiz is in no way evil and she
is actually very nice polite innocent
and even shy despite being a shop owner
she seems to be an absolutely terrible
business woman since her store has never
been profitable due to the fact that she
sells items that no one really needs or
if they think they need it they soon
regret getting it nevertheless Wiz is
well-liked by the townspeople and her
good-hearted nature and kindness make
her great and making friends she has
powerful magical abilities but as an
undead she is also weak to aquas
purification magic and she almost
evaporated disappeared or whatever you
want to call it as a result of it on a
new
whereas occassions then we have Luna a
kind and cheerful woman that works as a
receptionist at the adventurers guild
Luna appears to be a calm and rational
person and she is a calming effect on
others while Luna is definitely breast
girl I mean come on I did not like the
fact that she failed to stand up for
Kazuma while he was being arrested on
charges of treason for supposedly
working with the devil King even though
he was completely innocent the lack of
loyalty she shows Kozma here is a minus
in my book then we have Eddie's the
pretty goddess of fortune
she is aquas jr. and takes over for her
when aqua is forced into the fantasy
world by Kazuma Aries is extremely
polite and respectful of others and she
and Kazuma get along really well in
sharp contrast to kazuma's relationship
with aqua because it is as a goddess of
fortune she is very lucky which can
definitely come in handy for anyone
close to her and she is also worshipped
by a lot of people in the fantasy world
so she definitely inspires devotion and
loyalty aqua resents Eris's popularity
and she tends to make fun of Aries for
stuffing her bra to make her breasts
appear larger and heiresses interactions
with aqua tend to expose her childish
side finally we have Union megamans
childhood rival and a fellow member of
the Crimson magic land Union seems nice
enough and everything but her whole
purpose in life appears to be
challenging Megaman in order to prove
that her magic is superior this all
stems from the fact that despite being
the daughter of the Crimson magic
village chief Megaman ranked higher than
Union at the magic Academy and now Union
is determined to become a more powerful
magic user than mega mean she loses
points for being so focused on her
rivalry with mega mean since that means
that she isn't confident enough to make
her own way in life without relying on
others and what others think of her and
now the time has come for the big reveal
the true best girl
in Kona Suba in my opinion is my girl la
latina aka darkness I will explain why
in a little bit but first I'll talk
quickly about my first-ever
anime body pillow as you can see here we
have the beautiful darkness pictured in
her armor after a tough battle that she
thoroughly enjoyed and I have to say
that the pillow itself is very
comfortable and the image quality is
really good
I tried washing the pillow cover to make
sure that the color wouldn't run or
anything like that and everything went
off without a hitch
there was no negative effect on the
quality or the sexiness of the image now
let's look at the other side will she be
naked
will she be naked of course not have
some respect
darkness is from a noble family and she
has class bro class the second side of
the pillow is her Netflix and chill side
and it's also a high quality desirable
image no doubt about it
[Music]
when I was checking out their website I
noticed that the anime dakimakura pillow
shop has a wide selection of quality
waifu's so if body pillows are your
thing you can click the link in the
description and use the discount code
ADP - uproar to get a 10% discount and
now why exactly do I think that darkness
is best girl and the top quality waifu
in kono Suba she might be a quirky
masochist but she also lives by a
crusaders code of honor which means that
she might be a little kinky with you but
she is too loyal and honorbound to be
kinky with other guys
she is also brave and willing to put her
life on the line for the people she
cares about and although she really
needs to improve her aim she does
succeed in defeating veneer in the anime
with kazuma's help so there is
definitely hope for her aqua is
certainly a fun person to be around at
times but her stubbornness vanity and
tendency to screw everything up are a
big problem for me
mangu mean and union on top of being
underage come on guys jeez don't really
have much of a personality in my opinion
mangu mean is obsessed with explosion
magic and likes to give weird names to
things but her personality doesn't go
much deeper than that let's be honest
and Union is obsessed with overtaking
mega mean and her personality is pretty
much defined by that single feature Wiz
looks like she would make a very gentle
and caring waifu but i prefer girls who
are fully alive and won't evaporate
lastly let's not forget that darkness is
a member of a highly respected noble
family and the heiress to a massive
family fortune a great white food that
also comes with money and social
influence as a package deal yes please
however while I think that darkness is
best girl the title of best girls plural
has to go to the succubus girls these
lovely lovely succubi provide male
adventurers of excel with relief
and entertainment by allowing them to
have exciting erotic dreams and the
adventurers love the girls and their
establishment so much that they are
willing to unite in order to defend a
town and protect them and do you know
the best part
since darkness is a masochist if you
tell her that you are going to visit the
succubus girls for the night she won't
get mad at you she'll just love you even
more it's foolproof
I mean even Knox Taku couldn't argue
with that logic all right that's enough
for me on the topic of waifu's for now
let me know who you think is the best
girl and the highest quality waifu in
kono Suba and why if you enjoyed this
video be sure to leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell let me know in the
comments if you want me to do similar
videos for other anime like the true
best girl in attack on titan my hero
academia seven deadly sins and so on if
we get to over 1000 likes on this video
i will make more videos in this same
style as always thank you all so much
for watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]